India hon capital the threat of gun and
bomb attacks makes walking down the
street potentially dangerous for women
there is the added fear of verbal
physical and sexual assault any woman
that they meet it is a level of complain
about harassment
Fauzia CUFI is a former member of
parliament who started her own political
party she receives many complaints from
women who say they get demands for
sexual favors something that has become
common in the workplace this is not part
of our identity to be honest 25 years
back 30 years back when I was a child
when I was a student when I was a
teenager we did not face the same
experiences for women we do now so I
think most of it has come with conflicts
and culture of impunity and lack of rule
of law Afghanistan is still deeply
conservative and publicly accusing
someone of harassment can mean risking
your life but high-profile scandals
brought the problem into sharp focus in
2018 the sexual abuse of players on the
national women's football team came to
light and last year managers hiring
staff for the presidential palace were
accused of offering jobs in return for
sex but no one's been brought to justice
experts point to a trust deficit in the
system but the fact stories of abuse
have come out at all
may be a sign of progress I think where
I see change where I see possibility is
the fact that people women's expressions
has changed a great deal and I think
general aspirations have changed but
specifically women's aspirations many
women that I talk to regardless of where
they come from
urban or rural are different parts of
the country they have they aspire to
life's different than their mother's
method than their mothers they may not
aspire to necessarily need public lives
or even be each occator but they know
that it's not okay to compete enough at
home for instance in recent weeks as
part of ongoing peace talks the Taliban
has said that if and when the group
returns to the political fray the world
should be ready for a return in
Afghanistan the Taliban rule which would
mean rolling back the clock on women's
freedoms
[Music]
Fernan us for a time started them my
redline campaign to try and give women a
voice in a future of gana Stan all your
talk about what about me that if the
Taliban are coming back to suppress
another generation we will resist them
it doesn't matter if they're stronger
unless there is equal justice for all
Afghans it cannot be considered peace
even at fashion shows women remain
outnumbered but in the years since the
fall of the Taliban women are better
represented in the workplace in
government and have more freedom in
public life but many Afghan women now
fear their hard-won rights will be
compromised in any deal ahoo shy he
pushes both social and gender norms as
cobbles first and only female tattoo
artist a controversial job in
Afghanistan even for a man she's been
widely criticized but has her father's
support and says that's all she needs to
keep pursuing her passion from
businesses owned by women entrepreneurs
to women's only health clubs there are
signs here that women are steadily
carving out more space for themselves in
Afghan society Zayn Basra via al Jazeera
Kabul